the animal kingdom males are often
presumed to be the most dominant
but are the biggest baddest and fiercest
sharks in the ocean
email
the beautiful big female great white
shark came right under the boat here and
surprised us tap into Cutting Edge
[Music]
we can uncover what it takes
to rule the waves
[Music]
there are many differences between male
and female sharks
one fascinating factor is their behavior
but could differences in both sex and
behavior explain why some sharks attack
now to the high alert at America's
beaches lifeguards funded a shark near
swimmers about five feet from Shore
[Music]
in Mossel Bay South Africa Allison
Towner is investigating the shark
thought responsible for more human
fatalities than any other
the great white
if there's every species of shark that
you need to be extra cautious around of
course it's a great white shark
Allison sets out to locate and tag the
large female white shark here to reveal
its movements
and discover if females are more
voracious than males
the largest male white sharks grow over
13 feet in length
but what about females while both sexes
can actually get really large females
have to be a lot bigger in order to
reproduce
to see a mature female great white shark
is an absolute spectacle these animals
get up to over 21 feet I mean they're
weighing in around two tons some of the
biggest documented white sharks are
pregnant females they've got
physiological demands on their body when
they're pregnant
these enormous sharks must provide
nutrients to sustain as many as 17 live
young in utero each measuring up to five
feet long this could mean that they're
more hungry and that they're seeking out
food at the coastal zones
through active tracking with an acoustic
transmitter allicin can gain valuable
insight into the movements of these
mysterious females in real time but
first
[Music]
muscle bait is a really important spot
for white sharks and that's primarily
because it's effectively an aggregation
site for their prey we've got a seal
Colony with around 4 000 Cape fur seals
look at that predation over there it's a
shark taking a seal the most amount of
seals found in a white shark's stomach
with six full caped Ferris wheels not
pups adults we think it literally went
around the island chomping seal after
seal after seal
we didn't realize they were capable of
eating that much all in one sitting
could bouts of intense feeding like this
relate to females bulking up before a
puppy
control
we've just arrived at Seal Island we're
gonna get some Chum slit going into the
water so that we can get a white shark
to the boat then we can get a tag in
sharks may have the best sense of smell
of any shark species female great white
sharks what I like to call the big girls
often a lot of the other white sharks
around the boat will just scatter and
the big girls will kind of take over the
show
these Supreme predators lie on the art
of ambush
in the moments before an attack great
white sharks can swim in bursts of over
20 feet per second
[Music]
it isn't long before the first shark
appears
it's a large female yeah it comes deep
deep yeah yeah she could be exactly what
Allison is looking for
[Music]
at the back of the boat here
I'm gonna wrap my back
Allison must wait for the ideal moment
to deploy the tracking device
without
absolutely unbelievable we have a shark
that's literally launched itself out the
water three times in a row to the point
that we can't tag this animal the shark
will not stay in one place long enough
to deploy bring back again okay here we
go oh
shark this unpredictable is too
dangerous for both Allison and the shark
it is far too difficult but that's
science for you you know it's full of
surprises and white sharks all have
their own personalities
personality in animals is a pioneering
area of research and a team of
scientists are on a mission to
understand the mind of the shark
Rising abruptly from the depths of the
Indian Ocean
600 miles from the nearest land mass
this is the lonely Coral at all of
fuvamula
the fishermen here have swept fish Blood
and Guts into the water for Generations
inadvertently they are calling a
formidable Predator around from the deep
Dr Thomas vanow is a shark behavior
expert specializing in the personality
of bull sharks
now he is preparing to meet another
equally feared species
the tiger shark
there is nowhere else in the world where
you can get this close to Tigers so
easily in very shallow water very close
to the shore just a few meters away
Thomas hopes to use these unique
conditions to assess the personalities
of the local sharks
Mayors will usually have a bit more
energy and move around faster that's
also more skinny and a little bit more
cautious that females are usually very
confident involved it gets a lot closer
so I know for facts that they are shock
personalities that it's really hard to
translate that knowledge into science
you have to translate it into
measurements over years and years this
is the really hard box
thank you
hey hey what's up
I haven't seen one so-called suitcase
Thomas's hypothesis is that every shark
has its own very specific personality
if his theory is correct it could be a
sign of intelligence which might evolve
our perception of sharks I think there
is a big storm coming and it's pretty
wavy I hope the visibility is okay it's
going to be really hard
swell it might be
female personalities are different from
males Could This research then shed
light on the profile of a shark that
attacks
George Burgess is a shark attack expert
studying human shark conflict
the three species of sharks that are
most dangerous to humans are white
sharks bull sharks and tiger sharks The
Big Three probably represent about 80
percent of fatal attacks recorded in the
international shark attack file if you
wanted to develop a profile of a killer
shark you'd start with size
size of course is the most important
thing the shark has to be big enough to
cause real damage and generally speaking
females tend to grow to a larger size
than do males with their physical
superiority could large female sharks be
more dominant and possibly more
aggressive than males
Thomas intends to find out
[Applause]
follows the reef towards
towards from here the ocean floor drops
away to a depth of over 16
000 feet
it's from this Abyss that the Sharks
come
the type of sharks begin to arrive
but are they males or females which can
grow up to 18 feet long
known to have one of the broadest diets
of any shark species
the Tiger has a reputation as a
scavenger that will eat almost anything
claspers the male reproductive organs
differentiate the sexes
foreign
a much larger shark has arrived
a 14-foot long female is on the scene
swallows the entire tuna head in one
effortless bite
this female is at the front of the
dinner line
Thomas already sees similarities between
his work with bull sharks and the tiger
sharks here but what about identifying
different personalities of both male and
female sharks
I've been very privileged to spend over
a thousand hours with bull sharks in
Fiji and it's been a great opportunity
for me to learn more about their
behavior or their personalities you can
really assess which one is dominant and
which ones are a little bit less likely
to go into a fight
dominant female bull sharks seem to
behave in a similar way to tiger sharks
this is ninja it's one of my favorite
bull shark really impressive female
extremely smart so agile very skillful
those big females really have a presence
something very special about them
they're about far the most dominant
like the large female tiger it appears
females of both species can show
dominance over males
now he'll evaluate the personalities of
these tiger sharks and form a database
Miracle scale he'll score the tiger
shark's Behavior grading their
Confidence from safe to potentially
dangerous to humans I use it to write
down the different Behavior I see in
different situations for example if a
shark is coming to eat a fish head it's
one situation if a shark is coming
towards me a human being it's a
different situation using an ethogram
Thomas reviews the personalities of the
sharks giving them a score from 1 to 10.
one being very shy
10. extremely bold
if I take the average of all the
situation and that's giving me an idea
of how bold how shy the shock is overall
then I can compare this shock to the
others
[Music]
from the outset the females are scoring
higher than the males
when you spend thousands of hours with
the same shocks in the water you really
get to know them so well that you can
really predict what they're gonna do a
few seconds before you really develop a
special relationship with them it's
amazing
rating Behavior over extended periods of
time identifies the average behavior of
each shark
this can demonstrate unique individual
personalities
and if sharks do have different
personalities could this be the product
of their experience their environment
couldn't be their genetics
[Music]
Eric nice to see you Thomas is joined by
Professor Eric cluwa and his assistant
clementines of we
Eric is a marine biologist specializing
in shark behavioral ecology and human
shark conflict
I'm focusing you know better
understanding shock Behavior
Eric's compelling Theory could explain
attacks on people
if you accept the hypothesis that shock
our personalities it means that every
shark will be different one from each
other most sharks will never dare
attacking a human but you may have some
very few scarce dysfunctional animals
that will do it and we call them problem
individuals
problem individuals are sharks which
display a very particular type of
behavior
Can attack human more than others
particularly if these animals are very
luxurious and inquisitive
99 got nine percent of the population
will never attack a human but then you
will have one that will do it and
repeatedly tonight danger in the search
lifeguards on shark Patrol like Thomas
Eric's problem individual Theory relies
on demonstrating that sharks do indeed
have individual personalities
meaning some might be shy While others
are bold and that this individual
behavior is consistent throughout the
shark's life
also to prove that the personality trait
is transmitted from one generation to
another one that the young shark which
is bold will have either a mother or the
father that is also bold
Eric must establish the lineage of these
sharks through genetic analysis using
DNA sampling
if successful he may be able to identify
potential problem individuals in a
population
we are trying to use less intrusive
tools to get DNA from the sharks so
usually we were shooting the Sharks you
know with a biopsy prod but we're going
to try getting DNA through the saliva of
the shot Eric hopes that a shark will
bite the tuna head leaving behind a
tooth Mark which may be swapped for
traces of the shark's DNA
I am hoping that the shark will have to
struggle to bite and cut the head and
hopefully we leave its DNA
the head out of fuvamula Harbor to
search for the sharks
and they don't have far to go
that is a big one that is a big one
Tom this coordinates topside while Eric
and Clementine prepare to get up close
and personal ready to meet tiger sharks
let's go
hey Eric can you hear me how's it going
down there
[Music]
all right
where's the activity down there
[Applause]
just as things are getting busy below
the team on Deck throw in the tuna head
thank you
[Music]
foreign
traces of genetic material from the
shark's mouth will remain on the road
providing invaluable DNA for the
scientists yes that's this that piece is
okay that's very good
amazing
shots are really well marked on the
doors so we can recognize them quite
well
very impressive very exciting to see
this large animals coming from nowhere
females are taking over the show a big
female came she was Bolder actually than
the others
but then she left a nice piece of saliva
on the Rock very good but it works we
have photo of all of these sharks we
have the behavior of all of these sharks
and so we will be able to link pictures
and behavior with DNA and that's really
interesting because if some sharks were
sharing the same behavior and the same
DNA we will know that they will be
related and that's a new discovery for
us
we can better understand this link
potential link between behavior and
genetics
to identify a relationship between
genetics and personality Eric and
Clementine must use every chance they
have to collect more samples
back at base Thomas reviews the day's
activities to further develop his
understanding of the tiger shark's
personalities two sharks are going for
the food
this one is just swimming off
he's giving up straight away the shark
is pushing the rock even biting to move
the Rocks away to get access to the full
its impressive Behavior it's amazing
ah I love this truck she's so gentle you
know only a few hours with her and you
can already feel her personality
all those sharks is really great group
dynamics
you can see the small ones that are a
little bit more away but the big ones
are dominating the central space well
actually I will feel very safe too you
know if I was a four meter long shark
yeah true me too
this is such a cool place so many sharks
in just one dive so many displays of
different personalities I mean this is
great
in Mossel Bay Allison is still waiting
for an opportunity to tag a female white
shark
[Music]
keep on going yep the team set out to
try a new area away from Seal Island
sharks are known to patrol The Reef here
closer to shore all right Justin
sharks are less frenzied making them
easier to tag
oh shock
must act fast choosing Our Moment we've
got a beautiful big female great white
shark that's just arrived she came right
under the boat here and surprised us
and then I'm just gonna try and stick
the transmitter right next to her fins
back
oh
it's actually lining up the Stars you
need it to come past perfectly at the
right time with the dorsal out of the
water
okay okay
this is in whoa Allison attaches the tag
to the shark's dorsal fin a huge success
for the Expedition even though it looks
a little bit invasive deploying these
tags they heal very quickly
Flesh Wounds are common in sharks
especially in females whose skin grows
up to twice as thick as the males
protecting them from bites inflicted
during mating
so active tracking is almost like you're
in the mind of the shot you actually get
such a feel for what the shark's doing
naturally
you're in their world
now the team must track the shark's
signal to try to find out where and
possibly one she is hunting
yeah
very weak signal I just thought maybe I
was getting a ping from down here and it
would have made sense that she be lined
in Shore
we spent so much time trying to get that
tag on that shark and we just couldn't
get to her soon enough to get a track
with no time to waste the team set out
on a mission to find the tag female
shark with an abundance of prey across
the bay this shark could be anywhere
the white shark which generally prefers
cooler Waters tends to go after sea
mammals
considering they have to come to the
surface to breathe if you're a predator
at the perfect time to get one of those
animals is when the head's ticking out
of the water
investigative bites have been
demonstrated in the white shark in
particular
a quick try to grab something at the
water surface to determine what it is
whether it's edible or not
it's acting like the right kind of thing
it's the right size and I'm hungry
both mistaken identity and investigative
bites could account for a proportion of
attacks every year
But Eric has another theory
[Music]
there was the case of tiger shark in
Papua New Guinea that perpetrated up to
12 attacks on humans
without knowing the gender of the animal
people Call that animal big boy
lots of cases after an attack the gender
of the shark is not known
but I have the strong feeling that in
most cases females are responsible for
these attacks given the size of this
shark instead of calling him
big boy they should have called her big
girl
[Music]
in the year 2021 the international shark
attack file reported 73 incidents of
unprovoked shark attack worldwide
resulting in a very high number of
deaths but we have essentially no
information at all on the sex of
attacking sharks on humans but an attack
by a larger animal which would more
likely be a female is likely to cause
greater damage or greater harm could
these monstrous females be more
confident due to their Superior size
making them more likely to attack
foreign
hopes to collect the genetic material of
such a shark
a bold 14-foot long female takes the
bait
it is very important for us not only to
get samples of DNA but also to know who
they belong to and to make the link
between the personality and the genetics
of the sharks
Eric sees a tooth fall from the large
female's mouth
holds the DNA the team is looking for
when you're surrounded by so many sharks
it's very difficult when you're
underwater to make sure you can see 360
around you actually it's impossible it
is it is critical for Eric and
Clementine to work together watching
each other's backs as they look out for
the tunes you should not allow a shark
to come into the roof because then you
are in trouble
these animals they have an amazing
pressure in their Joy it's about half of
Jones per square centimeters you can
imagine these teeth the damage they can
do I prefer that not to happen to me
foreign
[Music]
is determined to find the tiger shark
tooth
wow
we got them big females and very bored
you know one of the shark had to
struggle to get the head and I saw one
tooth falling out and I was able to
retrieve
that tooth is from the first large
female that came and grabbed in order to
my head this tooth will be sent back to
the lab for analysis
could she be related to the shark that
bit through the Rope
with Thomas's ongoing ethogram studies
and Eric and Clementine's genetic
approach combined the team in fuvamula
are gaining unique insight into the
Sharks here
this multi-disciplinary study could
potentially hold the secret to
identifying what it takes to be a
problem individual
whether problems shark or not when it
comes to finding the Queen of the Waves
Allison's theory is simple size rules
she firmly believes there is a direct
correlation between size and dominance
one thing I've observed with great white
sharks if a large female comes on the
scene and there are other smaller white
sharks around her they move out the way
and it's almost like she's aware of her
own presence and power as well so
certainly the females assert their
dominance and it's absolutely
spectacular to see
sized females are the largest predatory
fish in the ocean
could they be defending a nursery to
protect their young
what a mother shock be more aggressive
and not that we know of there's
absolutely no mother nurturing when it
comes to delivering pups as white sharks
when they drop their pups after pups go
fully self-sufficient
nobody has ever seen or documented great
white sharks giving birth or mating
anywhere on the planet is like the Holy
Grail
but what about pregnant sharks could
they be more aggressive
Thomas is Keen to track one down to
assess its personality and find out
suddenly the sharks swim away
has something scared them off
a 14-foot long tiger shark emerges from
the deep one of the largest of the
Expeditions so far
and she's pregnant
[Music]
female tigers can carry more than 30
pups
[Music]
this encounter is short-lived and before
Thomas has a chance to assess her
personality she melts into the Shadows
although bold it seems this mother-to-be
is not so voracious after all
it's pretty well understood that
pregnant females when they're in the
areas where they're birthing or not
feeding
we've seen time and time again where
female sharks that are pregnant and
getting ready to give birth ignore
humans completely I'm unaware of any
attack that has ever occurred with a
pregnant shark
scientific theory
Theory inhibit them feeding to prevent
them from preying on their own young
could it be that a large female white
shark that's just given birth and is now
seeking prey may be sort of less
selective on what she's eating difficult
to support but certainly something to
consider look if you told me I wasn't
eating for the last term of my pregnancy
and I gave birth I would be seriously
angry at the end of that and I'd
certainly be looking for a meal
[Music]
Allison continues the search for the
tagged shark
[Music]
foreign
she's very far away
but I think I'm starting to get some
pings
[Music]
cheers we've got a signal and a good one
so now we're going to quickly change
hide your phones and we're going to see
if we can get a directional track on us
so that we can get Physicians and follow
around
we know she's within 500 meters of the
boat somewhere
Alison moves quickly to get a bearing on
the shark before she loses signal again
she's over here
I'm gonna lose her let's go
the team are just over half a mile from
the shore
who knew that she'd be down here all
this way from where we saw her
about these female sharks is that
they're just so unpredictable one is not
exactly really like the other so they'll
constantly keep you on your toes
okay let's go neutral
22 yes zero seven
so the ultimate game of hide and seek
with the great white isn't it
[Music]
Allison continues the hunt
even with a tag finding a single shark
in the ocean is far from easy so when it
comes to attacks finding the perpetrator
is extremely difficult
most sharks that are biting humans are
gone after they bite danger in the
search we have virtually no confidence
in the identification of a shark or its
size for most victims
I'm aware of three different times where
an individual shark could be documented
or hypothesized as attacking more than
once within a short period of time
best out of thousands that we've
documented
[Music]
But Eric is on the trail of one shark
which he believes is a repeat offender
in December 2020 there was a fatal
attack in San Martin
and one month later there was a second
attack which was almost fatal
these two attacks happened only 85
kilometers from each other
this is in an area where there have been
no fatal attacks in recent history but
are these two incidents linked
we were able to prove that it was a
tiger shark
and now we have ongoing genetic analysis
that should allow us to prove that
actually it is the same individual
the techniques Eric is employing in the
Caribbean could one day expose soon to
be problem sharks
the central question is why your shark
will bite a human being
but actually it's not the right question
the right question will be why that
shark beat a human being
what make that shock different from the
other sharks
to understand that we have to take the
different components of shark behavior
dominance will of course be directly
linked to the size of the shark but
personality will also play a critical
role for that dominance
we want to identify the dominant animals
that they'll participate directly to to
The Feeding Frenzy stay safe okay to
identify the dominance hierarchy in this
group of sharks
the team must collect the DNA of the
boldest individual at the top of the
pecking order
it's yellowfin tuna weighs 200 pounds
and is a substantial prize to claim
sending down the tuna
[Music]
shark that comes in to take this tuna
could well rules waves here
[Music]
the team don't have to wait long before
they have a contender
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
took time
but we made it wow
at the beginning there was something
like 10 shots among them there was two
large females
still suddenly in one very impressive
enormous large female that came wow I
think at least 16 I would say even 17
feet you know yes it was a princess that
is the real queen that is the big mama
the team have found a dominant shark
but with no genetic material collected
this time there is still a lot to learn
about her all the sharks they move away
they let the queen come to the bait
it definitely rules the Shacks
she is enormous she is confident she is
female
but do these factors make similar sharks
more likely to become problem
individuals they need to be bold but
that's not even enough to fit on a human
you also need positive reinforcement
through your own experience
a boulder shark could be more likely to
experiment with larger riskier prey
items
if unharved and rewarded with a meal it
is conditioned through this experience
to keep trying larger prey
[Music]
but if the animal does not have a
positive experience and is heard or
frightened it may think twice before
trying again
Thomas believes that using this
principle could mitigate against problem
sharks
when I walk with bull sharks that have
this special sound I use to scare them
to do negative reinforcement teach them
this is not something I want you to do
I was using a variant of the Doppler
effects
so you feel like something is going
after you really fast even though I'm
not moving
up it worked with bull shark but it
doesn't seem to work with tigers
I've tried many occasions in fuvamula
and because tiger sharks evolve to be
more vision and smell maybe they don't
react to sound as much
whether or not conditioning sharks works
as a deterrent perhaps shark personality
should be given more consideration when
it comes to human shark conflict
I don't like the mistaken identity
concept
because it means that all the sharks
around the world could make a mistake
all shots potentially represent a danger
on the contrary 99.9 percent of shots
will never represent a real danger for
people
only
0.01 may represent a danger and these
are the problem individuals
if sharks do have individual heritable
personalities
might this change our approach to shark
attacks
the main strategy to manage human
fatalities is to kill sharks blindly
without any selectivity
if we manage to prove that the
hypothesis of the problem individual is
true it means we don't have a problem
with sharks we have just a problem with
very few individuals
sharks are sentient beings and they
deserve respect as much as any other
animals
they absolutely have their own
personalities and I think that is such a
fascinating trait
it shows that also have thoughts and
maybe emotions
do sharks have feelings
I imagine they do feel pain but if they
got the emotional complexity that we
human beings tie to feelings that's a
whole different level of science but you
never know
can you believe it it's her look at this
she is a good kilometer and a half away
from where we tagged her
so close to shore you can actually see a
bunch of people on the beach and this
animal is just doing what it does
naturally it's patrolling The Reef here
if they knew what we were tracking right
behind the surf here just goes to show
coexistence is ultimately possible in
fact it happens more than we know it
Eric and Clementine must wait for the
results of their ongoing genetic
analyzes which they hope will prove that
personality is inherited and support
their problem individual Theory my dream
is to understand better the behavior of
sharks to improve the relationships
between humans and these animals
shock are not the monitor that we think
they are
as a new generation of marine biologists
it's up to us to protect sharks for
Generation to come
because of the million of years of
evolution females have grown so much
stronger so much more resistant than
this
[Music]
in the world of sharks the rulers are
the queen and not the king their skins
is sicker than the males they grow
larger than the males they live longer
than the males and they outnumber the
males
the females are 100 dominant
here in football we definitely met a
shark Queen
I hope that she and her fellow Queens
would continue to rule our oceans for
the many years to come
long live the queen
[Music]
thank you